[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo soy mariana somos instructores de
pilates y estamos aquí hoy para
compartir con ustedes una serie de
ejercicios que pueden practicar todos
los días para mejorar su salud postural
y contrarrestar los efectos dañinos de
pasar muchas horas en una postura
sostenida en estos tiempos de constantes
cambios hay una pieza que es fundamental
y de la cual no podemos olvidarnos que
nos va a ayudar a transformarnos y
adaptarnos y esa es nuestra salud si
bien es cierto nos estamos enfrentando a
muchísimo estrés emocional debido a los
panoramas económicos y la emergencia de
salud como tal también nos estamos
enfrentando a un estrés físico todos
hemos sentido como el confinamiento nos
ha limitado las posibilidades de
desplazarnos y como las
responsabilidades familiares ahora
muchas veces se combinan con nuestras
jornadas de trabajo y hacen que sea más
difícil sacar esos ratos de
esparcimiento y de autocuidado si no
hacemos algo al respecto podemos caer
sin darnos cuenta en estilos de vida
sedentarios
el cuerpo humano fue diseñado para el
movimiento entonces si pasamos muchos
horas días semanas meses e inclusive
años sentados en frente a una
computadora
después sentados en el carbón sentados
en el sillón sentados en la mesa el
cuerpo se empieza a adaptar a esta nueva
normalidad
es recomendable que hagamos pausas
idealmente cada 30 minutos o cada hora
el objetivo de esto es que nos
despegamos un poquito del trabajo y nos
dediquemos un ratito a nuestra
respiración ya nuestro cuerpo entonces
nosotros seleccionamos unos ejercicios
super sencillos a modo de ejemplo que
pueden realizar desde sus escritorios la
idea es que cuando nosotros los vayamos
haciendo ustedes los vayan practicando
con nosotros entonces listos estamos en
la silla que estén donde sea que estén y
se van a sentar hacia el frente de esa
silla con la columna muy larga vamos a
relajar los hombros y el primer
ejercicio es un ejercicio de respiración
entonces nos colocamos las manos en las
costillas y cuando inhalamos podemos
sentir que las costillas se abren hacia
los lados como un abanico un acordeón y
cuando exhalamos sentimos que las
costillas se van cerrando entonces ahora
vamos a inhalar continuamente durante
cinco cuentas inhaló 1 2
45 y exhaló 234
in a los 2 3 4 5 6
y exhaló dos tres cuatro cinco seis
inhaló dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
y la idea es que cada vez que lo
practiquen vayan sumándole a estas
cuentas logrando aguantar más de
inhalación y exhalación y así mejorar la
capacidad de sus pulmones y lograr
disminuir el estrés en el siguiente
ejercicio lo que vamos a hacer es
estirar los músculos del cuello y de los
hombros entonces inhalando subimos los
hombros exhalando los relajamos se
agarran del borde de la silla y dejan
caer la cabeza hacia un costado
inhalando suben los hombros exhalando
relajan se toman de la silla y deja caer
la cabeza inhalando suben los hombros
exhalando relajan esta vez se toman de
la silla dejan caer la cabeza y agregan
una rotación inhalando suben los hombros
exhalando bajan deja caer cabeza y
agregan una rotación en esta última
repetición lo que vamos a hacer es que a
esa rotación le vamos a agregar una
extensión estirando un poco más la parte
de adelante del cuello y volvemos al
centro inah lo sube los hombros
exhalando los bajos dejamos caer cabeza
rotamos y vamos hacia atrás y volvemos
hacia el centro
en el siguiente ejercicio vamos a rotar
la columna entonces vamos a volver a ver
hacia la derecha llevando una mirada
hacia atrás y regresar al centro crece
la columna y brotan al otro lado si se
pueden sostener de la pierna del
apoyabrazos vuelve a espaldar y eso les
va a ayudar a brotar más al otro lado
con la inhalación vamos a rotar y girar
llevando la mirada lejos abriendo los
ojos mucho y al otro lado giro estiro
sientan el cuello los hombros y la
espalda alargarse de vuelta al centro
una más de cada lado inhalación y
exhalando regresamos los ojos bien
abiertos volviendo a ver atrás última
vez y de vuelta al centro a partir de
aquí si se pueden poner de pie es
recomendable para el siguiente ejercicio
lo que vamos a hacer es colocarnos con
las manos detrás de la cabeza
vamos a presionar suavemente contra las
manos y exhalando relajamos si se dan
cuenta lo que estamos haciendo es
contrarrestar la posición típica de
estar frente a un monitor
inhalando presionamos hacia atrás y
exhalando regresa llevamos ahora las
manos a los hombros y vamos a hacer
círculos muy grandes con los codos hacia
atrás traten de mantener sus costillas
adentro y sientan como se abren los
músculos del pecho con estos círculos y
cambio la dirección bien grandes y
amplios los círculos 3 y lila white y
abajo para este ejercicio que viene lo
que vamos a hacer es que vamos a hacer
un círculo grande con los brazos ponemos
las manos atrás en la silla o en la
pelvis así como muestra de amy y
regresamos hacia el centro subimos los
brazos inhalando exhalando nos tomamos
de la silla inhalando abrimos el pecho
estirando el pecho y exhalando
regresamos al centro una última vez
llena lo subo exhaló bajo y la idea es
abrir el pecho todo lo que se pueda y
regresamos hacia el centro ahora nos
vamos a colocar con una mano en la
cabeza y la otra mano en las costillas
inhalando vamos a ir hacia un costado y
exhalando volvemos hacia el centro
inhalando hacia un costado
y exhalando volvemos al centro cambiamos
de lado la idea es que cuando usted
inhala este lado de las costillas se
abre un poco más y puedan estirar
inhalando vamos hacia el costado y
exhalando regresamos hacia el centro
ahora vamos a llevar los brazos al
frente y hacer puños con las manos
vamos a ver círculos muy grandes con las
muñecas lo más grande que se pueda y
cambio la dirección bien grandes de sus
círculos y ahora vamos a decir esto con
la mano contraria voy a jalar para atrás
los dedos estirando la mano la palma de
la mano ahora voy a ir por debajo a
tomar el pulgar y jalarlo para abajo un
buen estiramiento para la mano esto es
especialmente importante si pasan mucho
tiempo con el teclado el mouse o el
celular inclusive los músculos del
antebrazo y la mano se precarga mucho
entonces necesitan este estiramiento y
ahora voy a sacudir sacudir
completamente
para el siguiente ejercicio lo podemos
hacer a un lado de la silla llevamos una
pierna hacia atrás inhalando vamos a
llevar el esternón hacia arriba
exhalando volvemos hacia el centro y si
queremos aumentar un poquito el
estiramiento podemos llevar el brazo
arriba al techo e ir un poquito más
hacia atrás exhalando volvemos hacia el
centro se cambian del lado de la silla
cambia en el pie inhalando vamos hacia
atrás
exhalando volvemos al centro o agregamos
el brazo para aumentar la sensación de
estiramiento y exhalando volvemos hacia
el centro
ahora van a cruzar el tobillo enfrente
de la rodilla contraria si están de pie
les recomiendo que sostengan la silla
para el balance doblando la rodilla van
a inclinar la espalda hacia adelante es
importante que quede bien recta la
espalda y vuelven a subir y vamos de
nuevo a largo sentimos el estiramiento
en la zona del glúteo y regresamos y
hacemos el otro lado cruz o dolor
rodilla y alargó la espalda es
importante que esta rodilla no se me
vaya para adelante sino que se quede
encima el pie vuelvo para arriba y una
vez más me concentro en sentir a la
larga mediante el estiramiento de sus
músculos y de vuelta al centro
y ahora vamos a hacer un círculo muy
grande con los brazos inhalando para
arriba y exhalando relajando los hombros
soltando el aire soltando tensión y
estrés otra vez arriba
y exhalando una sonrisa en la cara y la
mirada lejos no vean la pantalla ni la
tele ni el celular vean algo que tienen
lejos con los ojos muy abiertos y listos
[Música]
[Aplausos]